This is our first programming assignment.
In class, we localized the robot in a 1D world
with a number of grid cells where each grid cell could have a different color,
and the measurement vector was a sequence of observations.
Our world was cyclic--if you fell off one end you would continue at the other end.
In this assignment, I want you to do the same for 2D roles of arbitrary dimension.
Just as before, begin with a uniform distribution as you always do in global localization.
Then we have a number of motion commands--[0, 0] is no move,
[0, 1] means you move to the right, [0, -1] means move left,
[1, 0] makes you move down, not up, and [-1, 0] makes you move up.
Again, the world shall be cyclic.
If you fall off one end, like over here, we continue at the other end, like the one over here.
Here is a simple example of the type code I give to you as a specification of the problem,
and then you have to compute what my code computes but that it can't see right now.
The world in this specific instance is a 3 x 3 matrix--3 row and 3 columns.
It has only 2 possible colors, green or red,
and this specific world has only a single red at the center location over here.
We have a motion vector and a measurement vector.
We start with a motion.
This one says stay in place, and this was says we're going to observe red.
Additionally, I give you two more variables called "sensor_right" and "p_move."
Sensor_right is the probability that the sensor measurement is correct.
In this specific instance, I set it to zero, which means the sensor value is always correct.
P-move tells you at what probability the motion is executed correctly.
Right now it's 1.0. It's always correct.
If it's a smaller value, then the motion might fail,
and when it fails, our robot won't move at all.
Let's execute this.
Here we didn't move, we observed red, and we had a noise-free sensor.
As a result, we get a matrix that says zero everywhere
except it's a 1 at the center location that has a red color.
Let's modify the world.
Let's make this grid cell red over here as well.
Then now let's just rerun the code.
What we get is a matrix just like the previous one,
but now we have winning grid cells, both of which have a 0.5 probability
so that all the probabilities add up to 1.
Let's now model a noisy sensor
and set sensor_right to 0.8.
Your code should now computer the following:
a 0.06 for almost all grid cells except the two winning ones,
which come in at 0.26 and 0.26 each.
Check that your code does this.
Let's now bring in some motion.
After not moving at all, I assume we're going to move 1 to the right,
and we always have to have as many measurements as motions.
So let me add a second measurement.
Let's say we sense red again.
Intuitively, this lands us in the square over here. Why?
Well, we didn't move in the beginning, we saw red--
there's two possibilities--but now we move again to the right side.
We see red again. That makes this cell over here the most likely.
Let's just check, and as predicted, almost all cells have a probability of 0.03.
Some have 0.13, but the one over here has a probability of 0.533.
If we set our sensor probability to 1.0, that is no sensor noise,
we get back this array over here, which assigns all probability to the rightmost cell.
Finally, I want to show you what happens if you modify the move variable.
Say our motion succeeds only with 0.5 probability
and with the remaining 0.5 we remained at the same location.
This doesn't affect the first motion command,
because success and failure is the same thing here. We don't move.
But with this one over here there is a 50% chance of moving
and a 50% chance of staying at the same location.
Let's run the code. Here is our posterior probability.1
The cell on the right still wins, but now with a smaller total probability of just 0.46.
If we now assume perfect sensors, by setting sensor_right to 1.0
we get this thing over here.
We have 0.66 chance associated with the right cell over here
and a 0.33 with the possibility that we moved this specific red here twice
by just not moving in between.
Check your code to make sure it gives you the exact same operative result.
Finally, I want your code to execute input as complex as this one.
This is a 4 x 5 world--4 rows and 5 columns, all with reds or greens.
There's only two colors.
There's a sequence of measurements of 5 elements and, correspondingly,
a sequence of motions of 5 elements.
All the measurements are green.
The motions don't move at all, move right, move down, move down, and move right again.
Then there are certain sensor probability and motion probabilities that I set at will.
I set it to 0.7 and 0.8 over here.
Now, if we look at the sequence, green, green, green, green, green,
we first don't move at all, then move right, down, down, and right,
you find that the most likely match in this world is we first sense this green over here.
We then moved right to this green.
We moved then down to this green, further down to this green, and right to this green.
This would be the cell with the largest posterior probability.
It is the 3rd row and the 4th column.
Let's run it.
And here is the result.
It's somewhat illegible, and I apologize for the poor formatting of my Python routine.
But if you look at these probabilities--0.011, 0.024, and so on--
you'll find that indeed the largest element is the one over here--0.3535.
And it's our 3rd row and our 4th column gives me this large probability.
I want your code to produce numbers just like those,
and we'll check that you got the code correctly.
In summary, read your colors, build a probability distribution of the same dimensions--
in this case 4 x 5--
Initialize distribution, execute a motion first, then measurement, motion, measurement,
motion, measurement, motion, measurement, and so on.
You can safely assume that the measurement vector is of the same length as the motion vector,
using the measurement correctness probability and motion success probability,
and then compute an output of just the final distribution.
If you've done this, you'll succeed.